Mortal Kombat annihilation is a movie
that from what I can tell no one wanted
to make and yet they did anyway
as a kid I liked it well enough because
it's hard to gauge quality when you're
like three years old but after something
like 14 years since the last time I saw
it I decided to give it a watch again to
see how it holds up after all this time
it was not glorious I'm gonna need a
smoke before diving into this
conversation and I don't mean nicotine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey smoke it's bad for your kids Hey
look at me I'm slay the boy and I have a
cool background graphic that people want
to make fan art of I ever needed
memorable costume what was I talking
about all right Natalie Portman fights a
talking bear I've seen a lot of people
list this one is another severed limb in
the mass grave of a genre we call video
game movies but I feel like there's not
enough talk about why it's bad most
folks like to poke fun at the surface
level things like the goofy costumes and
awful acting but I think there's more
layers to its failings than just that I
think this movie is special and how much
of a failure turned out to be especially
coming hot off the trail of the first MK
movie which a lot of people have some
reverence for despite its flaws we live
in the age of sequels and franchises and
reboots and trying again and again until
an idea works when it comes to movies if
a big tentpole superhero movie fails to
live up to expectations
they just recast and reboot right away
and before three years have passed we
have a whole new version of it but
annihilation didn't get that treatment
as established in my previous video
Mortal Kombat was a pretty huge brand at
the time but then it just fizzled out
and stopped one day well you can
certainly blame it on the lackluster
products and adaptations coming out in
mass a fair amount of those had
redeemable qualities I think the reason
Mortal Kombat faded out from the media
conscious once and for all
was because of this little Kombat
annihilation
killed an entire franchise sure Batman
and Robin is legendary for how poorly it
turned out but that didn't stop them
from rebooting Batman less than a decade
later franchises revived rather quickly
but a new Mortal Kombat movie is only
now picking up traction again in 2019
there was something so wrong with this
movie that no studio wanted to touch the
brand for 22 years the whole shebang
starts literally the same scene where
the last one left off with but some
things are immediately off for one Shao
Kahn's voice and appearance are
different because they actually cast an
actor instead of just putting whatever
they had lying around up on the sky this
opening recap shows us what happened in
the first movie but you may notice it
only shows clips of Liu Kang
doing anything because he's one of the
only two actors who came back Johnny
Raiden Sonya and even Jax are all recast
my theory behind this is because the
original cast knew this was from a first
time director which often doesn't bode
well for a big movie like this and then
they read the script because I'll boi
this script annihilation is based on
Mortal Kombat 3 since the first movie
was a mash-up of 1 & 2 in an odd way
including them going to Outworld and
Sonya being prisoner and all that jazz
so much like the games Shao Kahn
discovers a loophole that'll let him
take over earth and his ex-wife prisoner
is still alive he used some dark magic
to bring her back with her weird Medusa
hair and sonic screaming powers that she
only uses once for some reason then they
start invading earth Johnny Cage is
killed off in the first seven minutes of
the film and everyone gets their ass
kicked really they couldn't get the
original actor back for even one scene
like like he'd have been on set for one
day ari come on I guess narrative Lee
this opening scene is it's doing okay
like it could be worse but then there's
all these cool character designs that
have been mangled this poor casting for
every villain awful dialogue it's not a
fight we can win here
the hell is happening to the sky I can
see every seam in the texture they put
in the background why is it takes so
long to flip there god they're still
going okay they made it this movie opens
on a shaky note never really recovers I
think rather than doing that boring
format of breaking down every scene with
jokes and then summarizing it all with a
single closing paragraph of criticism
I'll like do the other played-out format
for reviews originality is dead in this
movie Kilda choose your destiny
Robin Shu is a decent Liu Kang they
never give him much to work with in
terms of writing but I still think he's
doing his best his fight scenes are
serviceable because he has a background
in martial arts and knows what he's
doing uh he's the only one I like when
it comes to the casting everyone else
feels stiff or weird like all these
other actors seem like they aren't 100%
sure what movie they're in and bring a
completely different energy to it that
contrasts in an ugly way when there
aren't scenes together the guy playing
Jack seems to think he's in a
tongue-in-cheek
action comedy while Sonja feels right
out of a Michael Bay movie where she's
taking everything too seriously despite
how stupid it all is this makes them
both have a really unfitting on-screen
chemistry the guy they got for Raiden
never at any point looks comfortable or
natural in the costumes they have him
where so he's just visually out of place
he doesn't have that same charisma and
mysteriousness that Christopher Lambert
brought to the role like Vilgax over
here is clearly trying to take this
seriously but he never quite grasps the
same sarcastic mentor vibe he seems
really helpless and unsure from the very
start of the movie and it's hard to
imagine this is the same character from
the previous one because of it I guess
Raiden's only at his best when he's
someone from the Highlander they do have
Harry Morgan over here doing some fight
scenes as Raiden to make up for the lack
of them in the first movie and it's a
boy those bricks sure do seem light this
fight he has with reptile is narrative
Li and visually ripped right from the
first movie the only difference being
now that there is two of them if they
made a third movie would they just stop
and fight three reptiles at some point
rendered inglorious ps1 FMV
what are they kicking stop choke on is
not what you'd hope for he's not this
imposing frightening figure he's too
small to really have that same visual
presence from the games and they can't
just digitally size him up like in the
games either his costume is so silly and
clunky that they have him wear it as
little as possible his voice sounds more
whiny than intimidating your world
becomes my world Lord Raven you hid
behind him your entire perfect life and
trust me I am an expert on having a
whiny voice and they made no attempt to
make him seem otherworldly or mystical
he's not a big scary monster from
another universe he's just some [ __ ]
dude bro he looks more like he'd be at
home in a fast and furious movie
everyone else feels right out of the
cast of a Power Rangers show just
gnashing that scenery in their frothing
Maz like a ravenous pack of wolves
you're alive too bad you speaking of
dude bros they made the wise and worldly
night wolf into a jealous jock that bird
dogs Liu Kang in some strange attempt to
prepare him for more battles so your
rates prodigy I've seen better then
sends him on a spirit journey to come to
some great Epiphany usually this would
entail drinking some kind of Native
American tear smoking some strange herb
but this movie has to make its cliches
as blunt as possible you've got to put
yourself in a dream state
instead he sends Liu Kang on his Vision
Quest by bashing him in his head with
the casual end of a tomahawk this is who
they cast as Jade I this is okay this
movie is chock-full of fights that have
no real purpose and don't advance the
plot in the first movie it felt like
they mattered because they establish
every bad guy at the beginning and why
it was important that they were all beat
then we worked our way up to it Sonia
had a personal stake in beating Kano to
avenge her partner Johnny wanted to
prove himself in a real fight and
battling someone like scorpion is as
real as it gets
Liu taking on sub-zero helped to really
establish his trust for katana Johnny
took on girl because he felt like she
was the most disposable hero and he
didn't believe he could do it which made
it all the more satisfying when he did
and finally shang tsung was a personal
battle for Liu Kang and avenging his
brother and letting go of his perceived
failures the reptile fight was [ __ ]
though I got nothing for that this guy
at that feature-length running time in
annihilation every fight is just bad guy
shows up hero beats them they talk about
it for a little bit
next scene smoke and Cyrax are two
really cool tragic characters with a lot
of emotional connection to sub-zero but
both of them just walk up fight our
heroes get their asses kicked and then
nothing else more is said about them
even the cartoon acknowledged that these
two used to be best buds what a waste of
such a handsome character sub-zero
establishes that he wants to be an ally
to katana and Kang so he creates a
bridge for them to help them along their
journey then scorpion randomly jumps in
they fight and then they both [ __ ] off
for the entire rest of the movie and are
never mentioned again Cyrax shows up and
loses reptile shows up and loses Molina
shows up she's katanas clone and Shao
Kahn's weird surrogate daughter see the
three of them have like a fan of Gamora
nebula thing going on there's a lot you
can do with that family drama dynamic
confines katana to be a disappointment
and creates this evil version of her
that he posits will be superior there's
some sibling rivalry as katana beats her
mirror version Molina is loyal to Khan
despite being cursed when the parents
she's
lots of stuff you can make movie about
but no she just shows up with no
introduction in mud wrestles with Sonya
because this movie has no class then she
gets kicked in the face so hard she dies
I guess everything is just a bunch of
filler devoid of substance and this
movie is already barely a feature-length
the fights themselves are weird and
weightless wire fighting where gravity
is a non-issue the performers are doing
as many flips and kicks as possible
without any of it actually connecting so
it's more like a bunch of interpretive
dance routines there's a lot of use of
slow-motion to disguise the fact that
very few of these people know how to
fight and I wish they could just stop
flipping there's so many flips then it
gets really confusing when Khan kills
rain to do that one trope but then rain
shows up again later to fight jacks
[Music]
you story is a long list of ideas
introduced with no meaning or purpose
it's just hollow decisions made to add
to the running time a lot of stuff
happens just so it can have no point a
few minutes later begging the question
why I was there at all other than to
just make the movie longer let's list
all of them shall we fight it Sub Zero
make a bridge if they could just jump
across
why did night wolf send Luke hang on a
spirit journey if the only realization
he'd come to is he's not confident in
his ability to beat Shao Khan even
though we already knew that no one
learned anything why did Jade team up
with the good guys contribute nothing
immediately teleport away after coming
out as a traitor and then get killed off
she basically added nothing to the movie
except a scene full of sexual tension
where she straddles Luke hanging in the
snow while wearing a revealing outfit
that would be super cold why did the
movie establish this weird robot style
hamster ball through underground tubes
if everyone would just stop using them
instantly it basically added nothing to
the movie except a scene full of sexual
tension where katana is pressing her
body against Luke hang when they could
have easily just faced away from each
other okay way I guess Sonia and Raiden
had to do the same thing off screen why
didn't they show us that Y is shinnok
even here they kind of hurt their
ability to make sequels by introducing
him so early and in such a limiting role
now he's not only a fallen elder God but
he's also Raiden and Shao Kahn's dad and
those two are brothers I feel like a lot
of bad adaptations try to simplify a big
cast of characters by just making them
all related or know each other before
anything important happens so they don't
need to build any connections or
relationships in the movie as far as I
can tell the only real reason they added
this element of familial ties was so
that Raiden would have a reason to not
brutally [ __ ] kill Shao Kahn as soon
as he stepped onto earth but he still
tries to fight him anyway and he doesn't
even acknowledge her act like on as his
brother until the final fight
I guess he let him throw him into those
bricks there because he loved his
brother too much to beat his ass what
are you doing
what was that
sindell has a sonic scream that can blow
up an entire building in a few seconds
she then screams at the entire side of
this Canyon and blows up the cave where
they find the matrix of leadership but
like she blows it up really slowly for
some reason it's on a time delay and it
takes like 45 seconds for the sound to
carry and kill all the heroes at once
then they say was a trap to lure the
heroes into a portal to Outworld so they
could beat them later but like what why
not just kill them now and it's not
because jade is a double agent they show
us she's pretty expendable later on what
are you doing what is anyone doing why
do you only have two of them out of
three you can just paint the SU rat
after you're done with it there's a
major plot point where night wolf shows
Liu Kang that if you have enough
willpower you can transform into an
animal I guess why of all the finishers
in the game this was the one they
decided to write into the script I'll
never know but then later Liu discovers
his animality animality and a malady is
to turn into a dragon but Shao Kahn is
also well versed in the art of
transforming into a rejected beast wars
design and uses all three cards to
activate his final form King Ghidorah
the effeminately screeching dragons but
then after all that they just stopped
being dragons and Liu beats him in
hand-to-hand this movie feels like it
was written by a small child that played
the games and had the characters and
story badly explained to him by his
older brother that was kinda high while
reading all the vials at the arcade and
then the emotional core of the film
Raiden's path to sacrificing his
immortality because he believes it would
be better to die as a human than to live
as a god in a world without freedom but
then the other gods just bring him back
instantly because happy endings
from top to bottom every single aspect
of this movie is incompetent in the
strangest ways when a lot of it seemed
pretty avoidable there's plenty of ideas
that could have been utilized and
structured in an interesting way if they
hadn't just won with the first draft I
truly believe there was a way to make a
halfway decent movie out of this because
well the first one was halfway decent
like I said that one kind of knew what
it was doing in a handful of ways I
still stand by my conclusion that it's
very flawed but still enjoyable and did
some things right
yet somehow every stupid chuckle [ __ ] in
the comments decided this was a
controversial take before repeating it
back to me word for word so I'm wrong
for saying it's a flawed but still
enjoyable movie because in reality it's
a flawed but still enjoyable movie it's
like you didn't even watch it your
opinions are terrible how dare you say
the same thing I will now explain to you
for the rest of my comment I see why
most youtubers are so jaded now you
people can be exhausting anyway
anihilation just can't seem to get
anything right the character arcs are
basic and by the numbers the effects
wouldn't have held up if this movie was
released in the 80s and it's so Hollow
and devoid of life it's just a bunch of
things happening with no rhyme or reason
and it's very loosely structured into a
story when people talk about video game
movies being incompetent cash grabs
they're talking about something like
this a movie so bad it made a franchise
into poison for two decades even if the
reboot isn't great it can't sink any
lower than this hey they've got some
great people cast for it and you can
almost guarantee the effects will be on
point it's hard to make a bad looking
movie these days not for lack of trying
even though Mortal Kombat receded into
obscurity and ridicule as a movie or TV
property after this there is still hope
though the games haven't missed a beat
and they went strong from back then all
the way until this year and beyond so
for the next round let's get back into
appreciating Mortal Kombat and the
medium it was meant for the land of
Technicolor blood textures and polygonal
bodies being torn asunder next time Sal
solo and Billy Mitchell joined forces to
become the deadly alliance
[Music]
[Music]